bonjour à tous le voit de plus 6 va être
très bientôt officialisée il va arriver
en france il va déferler en france
devenu un vrai succès au niveau du bac
+5 et de +5 cas l'année dernière on en
sait quasiment c'est quasiment tout va
pas se mentir sur ce nouveau one piece
le design les spécifications le prix on
s'est pas mal de choses on va faire en
pointant ce qui va être annoncé d'entrée
très très peu de temps donc on va
regarder un peu le portrait robot
quelques jours du lancement officiel et
on y va tout
le one piece va être présentée le 16 mai
prochain à londres
à 18 heures heure locale très précise
c'est très clair il ya quelques jours
une plus a lancé une grande campagne
pour acheter les billets pour être
présents à l'événement pas très cher les
billets d'ailleurs mais en 10 heures à
peine tout a été sold out complet
maintenant c'est plus possible d'y aller
donc à falloir suivre le live stream sur
internet ça vous pourrez mais en tout
cas si vous n'avez pas votre place et
bien ça vous est passé sous le nez les
amis donc nous vous inquiétez pas on
reste connectés parce que nous aussi on
va en parler énormément web plus c'est
une marque qui cartonne une marque est
super intéressante
le one + 5 était bien le one + 5 t a mis
la barre encore plus haut avec le one +
6 ça devrait être encore plus violent
ils veulent donc vous inquiétez pas on
va en parler énormément ici j'ai
quelques notes sur ce que devrait être
en tout cas ce one + 6 les
spécifications techniques fuite de plus
en plus et en plus de ça one plus
s'amuse avec sa pose des questions
directement à sa basse fans à sa
communauté
ils ont posé une question à savoir est
ce que vous voulez une encoche je
voulais pas encore à plein temps en
temps dit non mais ils ont dit on crée
pas de souci on va quand même là m bon
vous aurez la possibilité de la cacher
mais on va quand même là m non pas
qu'ils sont foot de la vie ou qui s'en
moquent correcte de la vie delà de leur
communauté
mais tout simplement qu'effectivement
aujourd'hui on vaque l'encoche est
devenu un peu un incontournable même si
l'on a même sur android ça serait
vraiment dommage est vraiment risqué de
s'en passer parce que comme je voulais
montrer ya pas très longtemps en prenant
le wahoo et p20 light en marge
boc j'arrive plus à parler je les ai vus
en voyant ce smartphone vous avez
l'encoche vous avez la possibilité de la
cacher vous l'a caché en fait c'est
juste que la petite barbe blanche
s'arrête à fleurs mais au dessus vous
êtes toujours les informations qui
apparaissent au niveau de votre batterie
au niveau de votre réseau initiatique
une petite icône mais ça ne sert à rien
de plus
ça devrait être exactement en tout cas a
priori sensiblement la même chose sur ce
point de +6 donc vous inquiétez pas pour
l'encoche si elle vous gêne vous pourrez
la cacher on voit en tout cas que ça va
être un produit qui va être super cool
super sexy d'ailleurs wayne plus jouent
le jeu un vraiment ils adorent qu'ils
essaient vraiment ils ont une conne qui
est vraiment top
ils ont réuni plusieurs membres de leur
communauté de leur base fans ils les ont
mis
une caméra et laurent duthe sonné ça
c'est les prototypes c'est les bonnes +6
ils vont ressembler à ça allez-y ils ont
filmé et ensuite au montage bien
évidemment ils ont complètement flouter
les smartphones étaient complètement
impossible de les voir on devine quand
même pas mal de choses par rapport à ce
que je vous décrire d'ici quelques
instants
c'est complètement dingue je crois que
c'est le seul fabricant café ça qui a
donné son smartphone dans la main à des
clients à des amoureux de la marque
j'imagine qu'ils ont dû signer quand
même un beau contrat de non divulgation
d'informations parce que sinon ça serait
vraiment chaotique mais c'est
complètement dingue parce que en fait
vous ont affiché à l'écran
lemoine +6 quasiment un mois peut-être
voir un peu plus avant son annonce
officielle
donc ça si c'est pas attiser comme un
damné je vois pas ce que c'est mais
c'est vraiment vraiment tout cas
vraiment super bien joué de la part de
bonnes plus alors votre but vous a
balancé plein d'infos plein d'infos au
compte-gouttes courtisé pour faire
monter la sauce avant la sortie de ce
produit alors qu'est ce qu'on sait
aujourd'hui je vais vous le dire on sait
déjà qu'il aura sept ans coche comme ce
rôle essentiel funds comme sur l'iphone
10 comme sur beaucoup de produits en
2018 qui lui permettra de loger un
capteur photo un capteur de proximité de
luminosité
le haut parleur pour cette partie là a
priori on devrait aussi avoir une
reconnaissance spéciale pour
déverrouiller via la caméra avant il
n'aura pas de système de failles seydi
donc ce sera un système de
déverrouillage comme qu'on peut
retrouver aujourd'hui en tout cas sur
les produits de samsung
bon comme un facebook quelque chose qui
déverrouille rapidement qu'ils parlent
plus sécurisés du monde mais qui marche
très très bien
rassurez vous on va quand même garder le
lecteur d'empreintes digitales au dos en
dessous du double capteur photo
verticale fonctionnait vraiment au
centre de l'appareil vous à
déverrouiller avec votre doigt très
facilement à priori la proximité que
l'appareil ne dérangerait pas on ne
faisait pas le dessus ça on le verra un
peu plus tard toujours est il que au
niveau design on va retrouver un bord
assez important en bas en bas de
l'appareil pour une question de coût
tout simplement parce que effectivement
autant sur l'iphone disent ils ont pu
réduire cette partie là avec un parti
quel écran un peu plus flexible en bas
pour pouvoir la gagner effectivement sur
la dimension
sauf que si one + faisait la même chose
ça à écouter tout de suite beaucoup plus
cher et ça a coûté beaucoup plus cher au
consommateur donc ils sont dus au final
on va laisser une petite bord noir en
bacs pas non plus énorme kippa
déconnante ça permettra de faire baisser
le tarif du produit et que le
consommateur s'y retrouve une petite
bordure
finale en face seul vraiment trop
problématique on devrait aussi avoir un
dos en verre à l'arrière de l'appareil
qui dit dos en verre dit recharge sans
fil côté craindre avoir un écran de 6,28
pouces au format 19/9 un écran oled
quelque chose d'énorme avec une
résolution qhd plus de 1880 par 1440 au
niveau de l'ouest on devrait avoir un
oxygène os 5.4 andré sur un android 8.1
oreo au niveau du processeur on devrait
avoir un qualcomm snapdragon 845 et deux
versions soit une si giga de ram avec 64
giga de stockage qui devrait coûter à
peu près 550 euros soit une 8 gigas de
ram 256 giga de stockage qui pourrait
coûter 650 euros dont je vous parlais du
double module photo à l'arrière on
devrait avoir un double module sens très
exactement à la verticale avec un 16
mégapixels avec une ouverture de f 1.7
et un 20 méga pixels avec une ouverture
de f 2.0
j'imagine un téléobjectif pour allez zou
mais dans l'image un appareil photo à
ses standards probablement avec une
grande ouverture prendre un côté un peu
plus grand-angle avoir effectivement ce
que ça va donner mais dans tous les cas
c'est ce que ce faire des photos de
plutôt bonne qualité la batterie devrait
être une 3450 milliampères heures on
devrait avoir un port jack pour tous les
amoureux comme moi des écouteurs
classiques avec son bon vieux jack 3.5
qu'on va plonger directement dans son
smartphone sans passer par des câbles
lightning et des adaptateurs que ça j'ai
encore ou encore pire des écouteurs en
bluetooth
moi je dis pire ça marche très bien
c'est juste que moi j'aime bien mon bon
vieux câble à l'ancienne et en plus de
ça l'info a fuité ce one + 6 pourrait
être disponible chez un opérateur
français y aurait eu effectivement des
discussions des pourparlers entre un
opérateur français leur imaginaire et
dans les plus gros seins orange bouygues
et sfr
lequel des trois peut-être plusieurs
peut-être aucun auront se produire
exclusivité chez eux ce qui en tout cas
permettra pour un constructeur chinois
des très bien positionné directement
avec des tarifs avantageux sur du
renouvellement de forfaits pour le
toucher beaucoup moins cher enfin
beaucoup moins cher initialement prévu
dans tous les cas vous allez payer
rassurez vous pour tous les cas vous le
payez mais en tout cas on va vraiment
que one plus progresse
du terrain séduit pas mal de monde et ça
c'est plutôt pas mal
alors c'est quoi l'enjeu pour être plus
parce que effectivement pour nous
consommateurs c'est d'avoir un produit
puissant intéressant pas trop cher quoi
que les prix augmentent quand même et ça
risque de continuer l'intérêt pour une
plus c'est de marquer l'essai avec le 5l
cinq tailles dernière ils ont vraiment
bien marché
ils ont fini de gagner des positions et
par le marché parce qu'autant les prix
deviennent plus avant était déjà
performant déjà bien mais pas hyper sexy
avec le one + 5 et surtout avec le one +
5 t ils ont continué en des produits
hyper bankable très joli et qui donne
toujours plus envie qui sont vraiment
alléchant là avec lauren +6 il devra
aller encore plus loin
continuez marquer l'essai et poings
coups s'affirmer comme étant vraiment un
des constructeurs de smartphones chinois
les plus forts et plus de tendance est
d'autant plus avec l'arrivée de xiaomi
en france d'ici très peu de temps donc
il est très clair pour roanne plus de
frapper fort et de gagner des parts
marché maintenant d'ailleurs dites moi
ce que vous en pensez à ce que vous avez
déjà eu des produits de bonnes plus est
ce que vous êtes intéressés par cette
marque est ce que vous auriez envie
d'avoir ce one plus si c'est en tout cas
comme je vous décris est ce que vous le
trouvez séduisant des combats tout en
commentaire posément toutes vos
questions suggestions avis qu'on puisse
en discuter tous ensemble si vous avez
d'ailleurs où des moines plus cinq voix
de plus 5 t et dites nous comment vous
les trouvez est ce que vous les trouvez
super coup est-ce que vous avez été déçu
si oui pourquoi
et sinon dites moi pourquoi est-ce qui
vous séduisent encore et toujours
voilà vous de marquer tout ça je vous
embrasse comme d'hab vous invite à
laisser des jolies pouces on reste
connectés parce que vous allez voir l
actu de latex ne s'arrête jamais elle ne
dort jamais ni le jour ni la nuit
c'est épuisant restez connectés et je
vous embrasse
soyez sages et à très bientôt ciao
[Musique]